today we're talking about cloud run
cloud logging
and best practices for compute engine
i'm roger martinez and welcome to this
week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news from the safety of home
cloud run is now integrated with cloud
code
making it easier to develop with cloud
run by incorporating
common workflows with your ide by
creating new cloud run services
you can continue to develop and debug
these services on your local machine
then deploy them with cloud run after
that once they're running
cloud code also helps you manage and
update those services
cloud logging was designed to help
developers and operators
easily identify the cause of
infrastructure issues
since easy can always be easier we'll
keep working to improve this service
for example we just launched the beta
for suggested queries
which will recommend logs that provide
context on your recent error reporting
groups
alerting incidents and other valuable
logging data
it's important to keep your vms up to
date with os patches
but managing that for large deployments
can quickly become a challenge
while there isn't a magical answer that
works for everyone there are a number of
best practices that you can follow
this list was based off of patterns of
other google cloud customers
with large compute engine deployments
and includes ideas like maintaining
flexible deployment groups and setting a
disruption budget
the latest google cloud white paper is
cloud key management service deep dive
which focuses on the inner workings of
google's cloud key management service
platform
and the key management capabilities that
are currently available
that's because we believe that making
encryption key management more
performant
secure and compliant will only be
possible if it's done
transparently if you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud